[Music]
during the medieval era
axes were more than tools they were
terrifying weapons that could inflict
very deep wounds
today craftsmen still make battle axes
for use in the entertainment industry
[Music]
the medieval battle axe was a brutal
weapon
with a single blow it could break
through a knight's armor
and fatally wound him
to produce an authentic replica for
movies and tv shows
the blacksmith consults reference books
he sketches the axe head design on paper
roughing out the details to the desired
scale
he cleans up pieces of old carbon steel
which he'll combine with other metals
in total there will be 75 metal strips
of varying composition
to complete the mix of metals he cuts an
old blade made of nickel steel alloy
into equally sized strips
he loads 37 strips into a vise
he tightens the vise and tack welds them
together
[Music]
he sands the welded stack he rubs oil
into the stack to prevent oxidation now
exposed to intense heat the metal layers
forage together
he spreads a mix of borax and other
minerals called flux onto the surface
this deters oxidation as the forging
continues
with the pneumatic hammer the hammer
slams the layers together
to become a solid laminated block
it's ready to be transformed into the
ax's cutting head
repeated strikes pinch the metal in the
center
he sprinkles the flux mixture onto the
surface of the metal form
heats it again and folds it into a
c-shape
after a reheat he inserts a layer of
carbon steel in the center for the blade
he hammers the c-shape flat leaving the
pinch section round for the handle
the 75 strips have been forged into one
[Music]
next the power hammer refines the handle
knob
he drives a steel stake called a tapered
drift
into the center of the knob this forms
an opening for inserting the wood handle
using the power hammer he now flattens
the blade end of the axe head
substantially
he flares it to form a cutting edge and
removes the excess with the plasma
cutter
he saws it off and the result is fierce
the axe head has taken shape but it
needs some refining
he hammers the handle area to spread it
wider
and dips the accent in water to cool it
down
then he grinds the blade thinner using a
belt sander
and rinses off the residue
he grinds it again to get rid of any
hammer marks or oxidative scale
the different metals react when dipped
in acid creating a swirl pattern on the
surface of the head
the first bath was contaminated so he
polishes it off
and gives the axe head another rinse and
clean acid
after heat treating and tempering he
polishes the face of the ax
and hones the edge
next he grinds spiral grooves into a
piece of oak for the ax's handle
a colleague stains the entire handle to
accentuate the carved spirals
and enhance the grain of the wood once
it dries
the blacksmith wedges the axe head onto
the handle
a few strikes against a steel block
improves the fit
finally he hammers upholstery studs onto
the handle
to simulate the rivets that reinforce
the original medieval axe handles
this medieval axe is ready for action
medieval axe replicas are authentic
props for any tv show or movie
[Music]
handled carefully no one will get hurt